who had a 294 era over his first 10
games gives up five against the giants
his last time here gives up five against
atlanta on saturday it's the first time
in 10 years he's given up five runs in
back-to-back games isaiah connor falafel
stands in kenner falefa bounces one past
the mound to awaiting chris taylor for
the first shot of the night
would he go to texas would he resign
with the dodgers
a chopper to turner and a couple of
ground balls
[Applause]
chopper to short one to second one to
third one to short one two three fulton
overall number for faulty this year in
12 starts a tough one in colorado's last
start but really a solid month of may so
runner first for muncie on a 2-2 muncie
it's a towering fly ball way back to
right field what a way to start the home
stand
skyscraping shot two nothing two errors
for the rangers one at shortstop and one
on this hanging slider and max muncie
makes some pay
max has not been really good against
breaking balls with that slider right
there he absolutely punished
ball one on justin turner
and turner lost one to right center
field that's well hit and that is
the dodgers go back to back in the first
playing home run derby against mike
fulton
quickly it is three to nothing
it is turner's 12th and it's three
nothing the swing and then the pose but
we didn't see any frustration in the
pose so right about now you think he got
this
and he got enough
i love it dodgers looking for another
one of those explosive knights they've
got two on with one out as gavin lux
comes up
slipped into center field garcia's
retreating he's running out of room
there's another
it's six nothing in the first
number six of the year for gavin lux
another hanging breaking ball max muncie
didn't miss it
and gavin lux didn't miss it
it's a nice looking swing
there's something of note here albert
pujols has replaced max muncie at first
base after one max muncie left the game
with right side tightness joey gallo
leading off this second
gallow hits one in the air to deep
center bellinger back to the track at
the wall who's got it
superstar athlete cody bellinger makes
the play and gallows the first down it
was an adventure tracking this ball you
could see him kind of stutter step
hesitate re-read it re-route it and then
all of a sudden he says yep he didn't
get it and he gets it right at the end
so runner in scoring position for the
catcher jose trevino sticks with it and
strikes him out great thing about that
slider to right-handed
batters with a man on second he wants to
get the out strikeout is fantastic but
this pitch you're probably going to hit
it to the left side and freeze the
runner and get the out over there with
the ground ball to the left side
clayton executes it perfectly
second strike out of the game for kurt
shaw now faces fulton
swings and misses he's down on strikes
top of the order and kiner falafel
grounded out his first time
home with another one-two connor falafel
watches strike three 92 with a fast ball
to stranded man at second and field will
come in for chris woodward with a man at
third and one gone dodgers up six
nothing
that's a base hit in the center lux has
driven in four it scoots by garcia
lux will stop at second with an rbi
double kershaw have a chance to swing
away here with a man in second and two
gone he wastes no time bringing a
basement into right center to bring home
gavin lux
clayton kershaw with an rbi single and
it's
dodger pitchers have now driven in 14
this year the next most eight is clayton
kershaw he's pitching with an
eight-nothing lead to the fourth inning
swings and misses and kershaw has his
fifth k including his fourth in a row
here's garcia grounded out his first
time on the 10th pitch adolescarcia
swings and misses at a slider that kicks
away from smith and he will reach
anyways
i mean it'll go down as a strikeout in a
wild pitch
runner for the powerful joey gallow
first one gone as the payoff comes home
and gallow watches strike three
seven strikeouts for kershaw each of the
last six outs have come via the
strikeout
here's solace with two gone
delivers in the dirt and his strike
three
swinging that ends the inning so kershaw
strikes out four in the fourth and has
eight in the game one ball and one
strike and there's a fly ball to left
field albert has lost another one oh
doctor what a dodger
albert pujols has become
this hall of famers getting better and
better as he rounds third and heads for
home
wow
lefty on the mound and guess what
happens albert pujols knocks it out of
the yard smith is hitting hard both
times has a double to show for it
the line hooking towards the foul pole
and gone
the fifth home run for the dodgers today
number six of the year for will smith
double digits
three and two thirds in
you know highlight
on the sheet is this the guy who's gonna
be a big difference maker he lines into
left field and there's that defense of
eli white what a great diving grab and
he very nearly doubled bets off at
second base that is a spectacular play
in left field by eli white bellinger
coming up first and second and one out
10-0 at the bottom of the
fifth does just that reaching out
slapping him in the center
rbi single for cody bellinger 11 nothing
they are checking on cody after this
swing he gets out of the box and he
looks like he grimaces a little bit
we're gonna take him out and make sure
he's okay so first and third one out
rangers trying to get on the board here
trailing 12-0 gallow facing the over
shift with lux moving to the right side
and here's a ground ball to the first
baseman pools he goes to second for one
a throw in the dirt the return throw
goes off the ranger dugout as kinder
philippa scores and it's a 12-1 ball
game kinder philapha extended his
sitting streak to nine games with the
double earlier
[Applause]
to second that's the game
dodgers all over the rangers in game one
a final of 12-1
long ball was working clayton kershaw
was working his back on track and these
dodgers have now won four in a row